il n'y a pas d'âge pour commencer à
dribbler avec l'école de mini-basket les
68 ans courtois de 5 à 10 ans apprennent
à manier la balle faire des passes des
doubles pas évidemment sous terre au
panier une panoplie de jeux et
d'exercices pour inculquer aux enfants
l'esprit d'équipé est peut-être fait
renaître les talents de demain
le but du jeu c'est de faire venir des
enfants vers le basket en créant des
jeux autour du basket
les enfants ont besoin de prendre du
plaisir je conçois pas faire venir des
enfants s'ils ne prennent pas plaisir
d'abord vous les gardez pas le but du
label c'est aussi de les garder
télé faire monter ou et dans les
catégories au dessus la fédération crée
de la belle école de mini basket en 2002
puis du en cours là toujours obtenu il
fait même partie des 30 premiers clubs
français labellisés en respectant un
cahier des charges très précis comme par
exemple employer un entraîneur diplômé
d'état
malgré la médaille d'argent derniers
jeux olympiques de l'équipe de france
féminine les filles ne se bousculent pas
dans la raquette
chez les baby et les mini c'est à peu
près équilibrés pu rendre en dix mois on
a deux filles c'est difficile on se bat
d'ailleurs pour ça parce qu'il faut
qu'on recrute des filles des jeunes
filles à guyancourt il ya une grande
diversité au niveau des associations
donc les filles vont plus facilement
vers la danse la natation
donc c'est dur de garder les filles dans
les yvelines sept clubs possèdent ce
label école de mini basket renouvelable
tous les trois ans